in one particularly exciting cross test  the foundation set scp-682 the infamous  hard to destroy reptile against scp-204  a cloud of deadly all-consuming nanites  bonded to a small child for the purposes  of protecting them as scp-682 naturally  attacked the child the nanites sprung  into action forming the shape of a huge  warrior with an axe and shield the  battle was intense but amazingly despite  taking tremendous damage itself the  scp-204 warrior kicked the stuffing out  of scp-682  as is expected of scp-204 its nanites  began feeding on scp-682's immobilized  body but surprise surprise as cp-682  started regenerating faster than the  nanites could eat it it then began to  attack scp-204 once again the foundation  tranquilized both parties and hosed  scp-682 with hydrochloric acid before  returning them both to their chambers  all anomalies contained no children  harmed